Right? So AI is turning everything into
a big tub of homogeneous slop and
readers are sick of it. So if you want
to stand out from the rest, then the
last thing you need is better prompts or
a perfect outline or a proven template.
In fact, that's exactly what's making
your writing blend in. So in this video,
I'm going to show you how the top 1% of
experts use their writing as an
extension of their thinking, which is
what helps them stand out from the rest.
the reason that most writers today sound
bland and forgettable even if they're
not using AI and how you can use a
simple two-step process to make your own
non-fiction writing more original and
more valuable to readers. And by the
way, if you're new here, my name is
William. I'm an English professor and I
help experts share their knowledge and
expertise through reader focused
writing. And in my 10 years of teaching
academic and professional writing, I
found that the top 1% of experts don't
treat writing as an afterthought. They
use writing as an extension of their
thinking, which is a method of solving
problems. And that's what makes their
ideas valuable and gives them authority.
I mean, think about it like this. No
matter what niche you're in, if your
expertise is valuable, then it answers
questions and solves problems. And real
problems are too complex to be worked
out in your head. So you can't think
first, write second. You need to use
writing to do your thinking. All right,
so this really got driven home for me
last week when I got an email from one
of my newsletter subscribers named
Alexi. He was dealing with a pretty
classic problem that we see in
non-fiction writing, which is the
tugofwar between writing and reading.
and he wanted to know what the process
is like because his process was too
slow. And that was a serious problem for
Alexi because he's a researcher. And so
when your writing process is slow, your
output is slow and your output is your
work. So it was really important to him
to get this process, this balance
between reading and writing right. But
he was stuck in this kind of loop. And
so he says he tried first reading
everything before sitting down to write.
And that was a little bit like cramming
before a final exam. Now, he said it was
actually satisfying in some way because,
well, he was satisfied of his curiosity,
but it was not productive. So, then he
flipped it around. He wrote first and he
barely read at all. But this made him
feel like a chef with an empty pantry,
no ingredients, and nothing to cook. So,
he was starving for ideas halfway
through his draft. Total dead end. And
so, his question to me was kind of
interesting. He was asking how
professional writers seem to write and
read together. Like, what's their
process like? And I'm going to tell you
the solution that he came to in just a
moment. But the really interesting thing
about this email is that as he was
typing his question out to me, his brain
did a backflip and the answer arrived
before he could even send it. And so the
solution that he came to was that
reading isn't really like raw material
or fuel that you throw in the tank
before you drive. Like it's not a
prerequisite to the writing process.
It's more like food. And so with food,
ideally you don't eat just because the
fridge is full. You eat only when you're
hungry. And so food is a solution to the
problem of hunger. And similarly with
reading, you don't need to read
everything upfront. You read when your
writing gets hungry. When you hit a wall
or you find a gap, you take a little
break and you let your ideas breathe.
Now, ideally, this reading activity is
guided by a research question so that
you're not just doing productive
procrastination. But I think that was a
very elegant solution that he came to.
But that's not the main point. The thing
that I took from this email is a lesson
that most writers miss. Writing is not
the final act like this neat little bow
that you take after all your thinking is
done. It is not on record of what you
already know. Writing is thinking. And
we see that a lot on writing YouTube,
but I think Alexis's story is a really
great demonstration of this because the
act of stringing words together is what
made his solution appear. I mean, in one
sense, yes, like Alexi was writing me a
question, but it was the act of putting
his confusion into the structure of
language that forced the solution that
he already had within him to appear. It
was the process of working out what he
was confused about that made him realize
this very elegant solution. And this is
why waiting until you feel ready before
you write is a total trap. For many of
us, that moment seldom comes because the
thing that makes you ready is the
writing itself. So that's why one of the
first things that I say to my clients is
always to forget about writing something
that's good, clear, or organized. They
come to me and they want feedback about
their writing style. But you need to use
writing in this first phase as a way to
generate your ideas. And once you've
generated those new ideas, then you can
worry about style and mechanics. But at
the start, your only job is to write
badly enough to find the gold on the
other side of your draft. Write first,
understand later. And by the way, if you
want to learn the art and science of
expert writing, then you are going to
love my free newsletter, Writer Science.
Link is down below the like button, but
I realized that this is something you
probably haven't been taught before, and
that's kind of the point. So, to see
what sets the top 1% of writers apart
from the rest, we need to rewind to high
school English class. If your teachers
were anything like mine, then they
forced you to write an outline before
you wrote your essay and then to submit
them together in your final submission.
You remember the drill. First think,
then outline. Only then, young
grasshopper, may you write. Thinking and
writing were treated as two separate
worlds, never to touch. Except, of
course, we all cheated. If you're
anything like me, what you did here was
you wrote the paper probably in 30
minutes the night before it was due and
then you filled in the outline. Now, we
were rebels at the time, but we didn't
even know that we were on to something
because at the expert level, this bad
habit is actually the perfect strategy.
Expert knowledge, whatever field you're
in, is not a neat little Lego set that
you can assemble in your head. Honestly,
it's a lot more like a pile of tangled
Christmas lights. And you can only
figure out what's actually connected
once you start untangling. So, the top
1% of writers do not wait until they've
finished thinking to start writing. And
they certainly don't write from an
outline or a template. They write to do
their thinking. And that's honestly the
way I think about most of my drafts.
Every morning, I open up a new fleeting
note and I just kind of do a brain dump.
It's great if you can do it like this.
Just if if you have a problem that
you're working on, you can write it as a
question at the top of the page and then
just set a timer and let yourself dream
while you're writing. If you don't have
a question that you're working on, then
just sit down and see what comes up.
These early drafts are not artifacts of
your thinking. And you're not going to
hand these over to readers. They're more
like excavation sites. I mean, sometimes
I actually think about a draft almost
like a lab, like a science lab, where
you're bringing different ideas into
contact with each other and just seeing
what kind of reactions you can get. And
a lot of the time they're duds, but
sometimes th this is how you get these
moments of inspiration, when you make
these weird combinations and you just
kind of let yourself get pulled by the
thread of your own curiosity. So that's
why I think of them as excavation sites,
your early drafts. As you write your
draft, you are digging for treasure. And
of course, there's a lot of dirt that
you've got to get through. But this is
exactly what Joan Ddian meant when she
writes, "I write entirely to find out
what I'm thinking." Expert writers do
not wait for clarity. They write their
way into it. Now, if you know exactly
what you're going to say before you
write, then you are not writing
valuably. I'm sorry to say, you're just
shuffling the same old deck around. And
this is exactly the kind of writing that
AI can replace. And so, very simply, if
you want to stand out from the robots
and everybody who's using them in their
writing, then you've got to do what they
can't, which is to think out loud on the
page. And so, now you're probably
thinking, well, wait a second. if if I
can't use an outline, then how do I make
sure that my draft isn't just some mess
like a pile of spaghetti that I'm
throwing at the wall? And that's a fair
point. So, here's the strategy. It's
called the reverse outline. And the way
it works is it's dead simple. Step one,
you write your draft. And that's where
you just let your brain off the leash.
Really helpful to use a timer here, but
basically, you're just doing a brain
dump. Now, step two, when you think
you're done, you go back section by
section and you slap a label on what
each part actually does. So, if you
can't label it, then it's either fluff
or just some Frankenstein's monster of
ideas. Step three, lay out those labels
in order. Just look at the labels. And
if the flow of them feels off, then you
have just found a spot that needs some
fixing. Now, ideally, those labels that
you've laid out are going to correspond
to the reader's questions and
expectations. And so, what you end up
with at the end isn't the map that
you've pre-planned in some template or
outline. It's the map that's going to
take the reader from their current
understanding to the new understanding
that you're laying out for them in your
document. So, the next time you finish a
draft, don't just slam your laptop and
walk away. Take five minutes, label each
section, and I think you'll be amazed
and probably horrified at what you
actually wrote. And if you don't use a
reverse outline like this, then you are
only doing step one of the expert
writing process. And to see what happens
when you ignore step two, imagine this.
So, you've just arrived at a restaurant
and now you're talking on a phone giving
them directions on how to meet you
there. What are you going to say? What
directions are you going to give to
them? You can't simply tell them your
own route. You need to consider where
they're starting from and what they'll
need to work through to arrive at the
same destination. And this is where many
experts get stuck. They're stuck inside
the idea that essentially there's only
one way to the restaurant. That is
there's only one way to do the thinking
and that's the way that the writer did
it. Now if the readers are complaining
about their writing then either the
readers are lazy or the writer has not
made their thinking clear enough. But
this is not an issue of clarity. It's an
issue of interference. And so the idea
of interference is that the language
patterns that experts use to do their
thinking interfere with the reading
patterns that your readers bring to
process the text. So whenever you are
doing your writing as thinking there are
all kinds of patterns that come up. It
could be just a kind of rambling
exploration, bringing in a lot of
background text, or you're basically
just working through your own confusion
and complexity step by step. But the
process that you took to move through
your own complexity and confusion to
arrive at the answer is not necessarily
the pattern that your reader is going to
use when they work through your text.
But the problem here is that readers are
not writing professors like me. So, they
don't really have the language to
diagnose what's wrong with your text.
So, they're not really going to say
like, "Hey, [snorts] your writing
patterns interfered with my reading
patterns." They're going to say
something like, "It's unclear," or,
"It's disorganized," or, "I just
couldn't get it." Whenever readers say
this, they're not describing the
content. They're describing the friction
between the writer's thinking patterns
and their own reading patterns. Like
these early drafts of writing as
thinking, they're supposed to be a mess.
It's an incoherent mess. It's a
reflection of your own thinking. And you
don't even know what you think until you
write about it. But the problem is, and
and writers do not like it when I say
this, and they don't want to believe
this is true, but it's the truth. Is
that you cannot just edit this draft.
There's no amount of clarity or
organization or, you know, move this
comma over here, change this word to
that word. There's no amount of those
line edits that you can do to make the
writer's draft more clear for readers.
The issue is not clarity. It's the
interference between the patterns that
each of you take to move from where you
start and where they start to the same
destination. So the top 1% of writers
understand that the route that they took
to an idea is almost never the same
route that the reader needs. So revision
is not just a matter of polishing
sentences. It's rebuilding the path from
scratch, step by step, starting from
where the reader is and taking them to
where you want them to be. So those are
the two steps to expert writing. The
first half is writing for the writer.
The second half is writing for the
reader. And those are two different
documents. But honestly, only half of
your expertise in expert writing is
knowing your subject. And the other half
is knowing your reader. So let me give
you a concrete example of how expert
writing works and the obsessive focus
that it brings to their specific
readers. Back in 1996, the economist W.
Brian Arthur publishes an article in the
Harvard Business Review called
Increasing Returns and the New World of
Business and it blows up. And that
article is still making waves 30 years
later. It's a fantastic read. It's
incredibly well written and I highly
recommend it. I'm going to link to it at
the end of this video, but let me tell
you a little about it. The interesting
thing about this article is that Arthur
didn't write it alone. He spent 4 days
obsessing over every sentence with his
friend, the novelist Cormack McCarthy.
Yes, he's the guy who wrote The Road, No
Country for Old Men, and he's widely
considered to be one of the greatest
American authors of all time. Now,
anybody who's read McCarthy knows that
he's very spare and he can be ruthless
in his edits. He was very inspired by
Hemingway. But honestly, the really
interesting thing that I want to draw
your attention to in this article is not
the words that they cut, but the words
that they chose to keep. So, keep in
mind, this is an academic economist, and
he's writing in the Harvard Business
Review, which is a prestigious
publication, but specifically, it's a
publication that's read by people who
are practicing business strategies. So,
that would be consultants and CEOs and
those kinds of people. He's not writing
to an academic audience. So notice that
Arthur could have written, I don't know,
something like early market entry
produces compounding benefits. But
McCarthy would not let him write
something like that for this audience.
So instead, he writes, "It pays to hit
the market first. It pays." Isn't that
interesting? You would never find that
phrase in an academic journal, but
that's exactly the point. This phrase is
an uppercut to hit his specific readers
right in the values. The readers of the
Harvard Business Review are people who
wake up in the morning thinking about
returns. So, it pays is a code word. It
says, "Hey reader, this is about your
world and this matters to you." And this
approach is everywhere in this article.
You see words like strategy, competitive
advantage, market lockin. Not the dry
technical terms that you would expect to
find in a dusty economics journal, but
the ones that resonate with that
audience in that context and signal
value to those specific readers. Code
words like this are like a secret
handshake with your reader to let them
know that you understand them and you
speak their language. But the reason
that readers value them is not because
they carry some valuable idea. No, no.
Value is not set by the writer or even
by the content, the ideas. Value is in
the eye of the reader. The language that
makes a startup founder sit up and pay
attention is not the language that makes
a Fortune 500 exec lean in and listen
closely. even if you're making exactly
the same point. Now, yes, there are some
more universal words that span across
genres with different reading
communities which signal value. Those
are words like but, however, although,
and those are signs of instability and
contrast, which is catnip for the
curious brain. But if you want to
establish value with your specific
readers, then what you need are
communityspecific code words. These are
words that tell your reader, I know your
world. I speak your language. I'm one of
you and I'm talking specifically to you.
And these code words are actually quite
fun to go hunting for. So, this is
something I always do with my clients,
but hey, you can try it out yourself,
which is whenever you are going to
publish something, of course, take a
close look at your readers, consider
maybe there's a journal that they all
read or maybe there is an article online
that they've all been sharing, right?
You're going to look at these almost
like an anthropologist. You're going to
look for these cultural artifacts that
they share among themselves. And then in
those documents, you scan it looking for
these community specific code words. If
you were to read the Harvard Business
Review, you would find language like
that. Strategy, uh, payoff, competitive
advantage. But no matter your niche, you
are writing to specific communities of
readers. And for them to value your
ideas, you need to produce that value
using their in-group code words. And
this is why writers who are agnostic
about their audience and just trying to
write for everybody never quite make it.
Arthur's article became a classic, not
just because the idea was good.
Honestly, there are plenty of good ideas
that just die away in obscurity.
Arthur's article broke through because
he and McCartney had X-ray vision on
their audience. They knew exactly who
those readers are, what they cared
about, and what kept them up at night,
and what words would light up their
mental dashboard. And to find out how
they did it, you need to watch this
video next because it is my deep dive
into this article by Arthur and
McCartney. And not only is it going to
give you some strategies that McCartney
gave to Arthur when they were revising
his draft, but it's also going to give
you a concrete case study in expert
writing. So, be sure to go check it out.